noam chomsky needs little introduction
he's revolutionized the field of
linguistics and in many ways he founded
that field
ordinarily he's asked questions ad
nauseum about politics
and i'm wholly uninterested in that this
channel is geared toward answering the
question of what is the theory of
everything if there is one that is
making progress toward theories of
everything
theoretical physics and consciousness
it's because of this latter topic that
we chose to stay within the purview of
psychology
philosophy and cognitive science with
noam chomsky there are a couple sponsors
to today's podcast
algo is an end-to-end supply chain
optimization software company
with software that helps business users
optimize sales and operations
planning to avoid stockouts reduce
returns and inventory write-downs
while reducing inventory investment it's
a supply chain ai that drives smart roi
headed by an equally bright individual
by the name of amjad hussein
who has been a huge supporter of this
podcast
nearly since its inception the second
sponsor is brilliant
brilliant illuminates the soul of math
engineering and science
through bite-sized interactive learning
experiences brilliant's courses explore
the laws that shape our world
elevating math and science from
something to be feared to a delightful
experience of guided discovery
more on them later if you'd like to hear
more conversations like this then please
do consider supporting at patreon.com
i've also recently opened up a crypto
and a paypal account so feel free to
donate through whichever medium you feel
most comfortable with these podcasts
tend to take plenty of preparation
and i would like to do them more
frequently with more intensity
for example at the end of august we have
yoshibach and donald hoffman
coming on to discuss the nature of
consciousness and actually tomorrow we
have kevin knuth
and jacques vallee on ufos thank you so
much no matter what you choose
this channel may as well be called
theories of gnome because of how often
we've had gnome chomsky on
he's now a dear friend and perhaps
there'll be a sixth time so if you want
feel free to leave some questions in the
comments and i'll
call and collect them for later if you
also want to facilitate the
understanding and perhaps the
cultivation of one's own
theory of everything or our own theory
of everything for this channel then
please join the discord there's plenty
of
wonderful astute conversation happening
there and
i'm constantly impressed with the level
of civility
and even ingenuity displayed in that
discord
thank you so much and enjoy
okay professor thank you for coming
very pleased to be with you again we'll
start
with question number 41 that is steven
wolfram
asks is it true that we may have a
description
of how brains work slash process
language at a microscopic level
and we still may not have a satisfactory
science of linguistics
that is that the lower level doesn't
necessarily inform us about the
higher level well
first of all the idea of a description
of how
brains work at a microscopic level is
a dream people don't even know where to
look
so for example it's there's very good
arguments that
uh the computational
work done by the brain even in animals
like
instinct insects is
at the probably at the cellular level
even internal to the cells uh
not at the neuronal level but
the fact of the matter is that if you
had
detailed information say about
cells or about atoms or
whatever would tell you very little
about the
way in which systems work
you could know everything about how the
atoms worked in a car and you wouldn't
know how the car works
but these are just at a different level
of organization
the next question will be question
number one
which is from sebastian campers
and he asks is there meaning outside
language
depends what you mean by meaning
[Music]
the term is very loose it's an english
word
doesn't translate very well into other
languages
in english the term is used very loosely
so you talk about the meaning of life
you know the meaning of
the stars and anything
so the question has no answer unless
you specify what you mean by meaning we
unders there is a
problem of meaning in language what do
the
words and expressions of language mean
the rest is metaphor
okay we'll do question number two which
is from air on
and he asks or she asks are you more
proud of your contributions to
linguistics or your contributions to
politics
well i don't think it's a question of
pride it's just
if i look at objectively at the
contributions
the ones to linguistics are far more
substantive
in the domain of politics
pretty much everything you say is on the
surface
there isn't much of any particular depth
to see
okay then we'll get to question number
32
and it says cowicide cowacide asks
how can one discuss philosophy while
staying non-political
by discussing philosophy while staying
non-political
it's uh i mean
in a sense there are human consequences
to almost anything you do
but when you're discussing for example
the
you know the problem of uh
take any problem of philosophy that you
like
uh how do you uh
what's the basis for deciding whether a
scientific theory is the right one or
not
what are the criteria for determining
that question of
science philosophy of science there's
nothing political about it
uh anyone whatever with any
political view whatsoever can discuss it
i mean a lot of my own work when i was
for many years with was happened to be
with
distinguished philosophers who were at
the absolute
opposite end of the spectrum for me
politically
but it had no effect on our uh
philosophical discussions some people
say that you can't discuss
philosophy without being political and
that virtually everything we do
is political somehow do you agree with
that
i think it's everything we do
there are things that are have so
few human consequences
that to say that they're political is
meaningless
like uh discussing say with
van quine first philosophy teacher
one of the first the question of whether
there are whether you can make a
distinction between
analytic and synthetic sense
is there anything political about them
if so what is it
okay we'll move on to question 33 the
next one air on again
what are your thoughts on mandating
vaccines
well it's a mixed story i think
we people who refuse to accept
vaccines i think the right
response for them is not to force them
to
but rather to insist that they be
isolated
if people decide
i am willing to be a danger to the
community
by refusing a vaccine they should then
say well i also have the decency to
isolate myself
okay i don't want a vaccine but i don't
have the right to run around harming
people
i'll just that should be a convention
enforcing is a different question it
should be
understood and we should try to get it
to be understood
if it really reaches the point where
they are
severely endangering people then of
course you have to do something about it
so if someone uh if smallpox
turns out to
become rampant again and some people are
insisting on running around the public
places
where they might have smallpox well
you've got to do something with them
we're not at quite that situation but
it's a
similar one so i think we should first
attempt to establish
conventions that will be
understandable by people with some
[Music]
moral capacity try to convince them
that it's your right to refuse to get a
vaccine
but then it is your responsibility to
isolate yourself
so you don't harm others bulldog
number 34 i would really like to know
how chomsky avoids despair
given all that's wrong in the world and
also given the shortness and potential
meaninglessness of life
well i've had 92 years which
doesn't seem short never thought that
life was meaningless
thought it was constantly rich in
opportunities significance happiness
aspirations i don't know anything
that's meaningless about that another
way to avoid
despair is to recognize how much
you can achieve if you devote yourself
to it
now you can look over the past record
see i can look over say
pretty much 85 years save
conscious life conscious of what's
happening in the world
and there have been enormous changes not
all to the good
but many very positive they haven't just
happened
they weren't miracles they happened
because people
did not succumb to despair
and feelings of meaningless
meaninglessness
but devoted themselves to improving the
world
people whose names we don't know endless
numbers of them
and it's made a difference and it
happens right to the present moment
right to the present moment you can see
it in
today's newspapers there are things that
people are willing to say and understand
and comprehend now that
wouldn't have been understood at all not
very long ago
so for example we can open the new york
times today
and read an article by
benjamin applebaum writes about social
issues on
how the the
legal system that uh distributes
funds to unemployed workers how it
functions
and it as it points out it functions on
pure
racist grounds established in the
1930s 1940s
because racist southern states
did not want federal benefits to go
to their mostly black workers
we still have a residue of that today
but at least today that's generally
can be generally condemned not by the
republican party
but by others and it can be
an issue which you can try to move to
change
okay pick that at random because it
happens to be an article i just read but
you can pick almost
random and find similar things the world
in many ways is
there are serious significant
improvements
higher understanding greater sensibility
changes small changes policy plenty of
problems
plenty of reasons for being
concerned deeply upset but not despair
because it can be changed you despair
when you think it can't be changed
and that's not true can be
thank you we'll get to question 37
and that's from amjad hussein and for
those
watching amjad is a huge supporter of
the podcast thank you his company
algo which you can look it up algo.com
supports this podcast as a sponsor of it
amjad asks
how do we differentiate between good
science and pseudoscience
do we need pseudoscience sometimes also
called fringe science
to do ideation and experimentation and
eventually some of those pseudo-fringe
scientific ideas
move toward becoming real science with
predictive powers
with predictive power and weight and
ways to test falsifiability
so how do we differentiate between good
science and pseudoscience
i would put a little bit differently how
do we differentiate between
good science and science that's not so
good i don't know what pseudoscience i
mean there is pseudoscience
pretense okay we don't want just
pretense
but within the search for
understanding uh
truth the basic goals of science
there are many approaches the ones that
are
we find which ones are the good ones by
inquiry debate critical analysis
experimentation discussion
uh free interchange uh all the methods
that are
available to us and that over time
tends to lead to selecting the
scientific ideas that are the more
viable ones
and the better ones it's not a yes or no
it's not a yes or no business so for
example the
ideas that were considered very marginal
not taken seriously for a long time even
physics let alone other sciences
later or discovered to have
high degears credibility and worth
pursuing you always keep them on the
shelf
think about them it's not pseudoscience
it's just
ideas that don't seem to make any sense
at some particular time
they might later run meanwhile you just
keep pursuing the only methods that you
have
critical careful analysis
uh careful study of the data
debate and discussion about ideas and
theories
experimentation when it's appropriate
and out of that mixture of options comes
a
general move towards better science
doesn't happen in a day i take uh
isaac newton's theories i mean they were
considered so exotic
that at his own university in cambridge
they weren't even taught for about 40 or
50 years
well by now soon after that they just
became
scientific common sense that's the way
science functions
we'll get to question 39
39 that is crypto nd asks do you believe
that bitcoin could potentially lead to a
true monetary and fiscal revolution
or do you think things will stay the
same and perhaps even get worse
well first of all i'm no specialist on
this topic
but so my opinions don't really amount
to very much
but for what they're worth i don't see
any sign
that bitcoin is replacing
uh is coming to anything like a monetary
or fiscal revolution
i suspect it's for the moment
kind of a fad
part extraordinary amounts of energy
very serious problem
okay we'll get to question five from
page one
and that's from global digital direct
subsidiary democracy asks
does chomsky think that blockchain
technology could be utilized to create a
direct democratic
voting system
i haven't seen any proposal to that
effect
and i don't think that the problems of a
democratic voting system are technical
they're not questions of how to make it
work smoothly
there are very serious problems in a
democratic system
to take a pretty obvious problem
simply ask the question whether
uh under our system or any
modification of it that might be given
by digital technology
whether voters are represented
by their own representatives it's a
pretty straightforward question
fair measure of democracy pretty easy to
study
you study the attitudes and preferences
of voters
compare it with the votes of their own
representatives
that has been done in very sophisticated
ways
uh the most recent study by
mcguire and de la hunt that uses all
sorts of
sophisticated deep learning and so on
and so forth
comes out with pretty much the same
results as other studies
the large majority of voters are not
represented
their own representatives act
independently of what the preferences of
the
electors are of their voters they're
listening to other voices
and we know exactly how it works if
you're
in the maguire de la hunt they say maybe
it's up to 90 percent
other estimates have been 70
but as you move and of course it's the
lower
the lower part of the income spectrum
the wealth spectrum so as you get to the
higher
levels yes of course they're represented
in fact
those are the voices that their
representatives are listening to
and the reasons a lot of the reasons
have a lot to do with things that have
nothing to do with blockchain technology
or anything else
simply the distribution of wealth in the
society
and the way in which that enters the
political system
through for example campaign funding so
if you're elected to congress
the first thing you do first day in
office
is start calling the mega donors
the people who have lots of money to
contribute to campaigns
because you have to start preparing the
funding for the next campaign
campaign electability is predictable
with
very high precision simply by looking at
the variable of campaign funding
thomas ferguson's political scientist
has
done the main work on this very high
predictability
so you're on the phone talking to the
donors
uh meanwhile hordes of law corporate
lobbyists
are invading your office to talk to the
staff
overwhelming them with all sorts of
claims evidence demands and so on
staff may be very good people but
they're not going to be able to
deal with this massive power so i end up
with legislation written
substantially by the corporate lobbyists
the same people who the representative
is
talking to on the phone to try to get
funding for his next elections
it's not a hundred percent of what
happens but it's
a very substantial part of the political
system
so out of that kind of arrangement
comes a enormous gap
between voters and their own
representatives
for all but the very top of the income
level
no technical problem was going to
overcome that it's the wrong place to
look
so whether blockchain could do anything
i don't know
it would have no effect on this
john doe the question seven john doe
wants to know
what does chomsky think about the latest
ufo slash uap revelations
confirmed by the pentagon
well i think the word revelation is
a little strong i would say claims
uh we don't know what they mean there
are lots of possible explanations for
why
and how plain pilot would think he's
seeing something
uh i think ufo is one of the least
likely
explanations for so let's look at the
evidence
that was an open mind but uh
quite frankly i don't expect anything to
cover it
okay we'll get to question 17.
this is also about aliens
if we were to make contact with aliens
what kind of language
could we use to ask them questions like
where are you from why are you here etc
and this is from patrick o'donnell
well if we first of all it's very
unclear
that there are intelligent aliens
anywhere within the parts of the
universe
that are accessible to us remember there
are
physical constraints on what parts of
the universe
are accessible those huge
enormous number of planets very similar
to ours
but that doesn't mean that you're going
to find intelligent life
in fact there's some evidence that uh
recent studies that show that the
probability of reaching the
even cellular complexity that allows
life let alone intelligent life are
quite small
so there's no reason to assume that
there is intelligent life we might
literally be alone in the parts of the
universe that are accessible to us
but suppose we do run into that might
be the answer to the famous fermi part
paradox
where are the you know all these
planets around which are very much like
ours
how come we don't get any indication of
any intelligent life
you look at what we call intelligent
life on earth if
if by intelligent you mean something
like human intelligence
my dog is intelligent but it's not going
to communicate with aliens
so if we mean the kind of intelligence
that would allow this question to be
raised
it's a phenomenal accident
it only happened life has been around on
earth for
almost four billion years until
maybe a couple hundred thousand years
ago
this question couldn't even been asked
okay it's a instant of evolutionary time
and it's the result of a long series of
accidents
which could have turned out some other
way so
we don't know but suppose there is
suppose we do make some contact
well the first question would probably
be
how much is two plus two
the one thing that
intelligent life is likely to have
is arithmetic and there are
pretty good reasons for that there's
quite interesting studies by
marvin minsky one of the founders of
artificial intelligence and
uh very smart guy friend
colleague died a couple years ago he was
one of those scientists who was very
interested in the possibility of making
contact with aliens
and he and one of his students back in
the 80s
60s did a interesting study
they took what are called touring
machines
abstract computers computer
not doesn't matter what the physical
structure is just
think of it the way a computer functions
abstractly
and they studied the simplest ones the
ones with the fewest states
and the fewest symbols and
just let them kind of run free see what
they would do
it turns out that almost all of them
crashed
they either ran into
endless cycles or one or another way
just crashed
some survived
the ones that survived produced the
successor function
the function one two three four
which is the foundation of arithmetic if
you have the successor function
you can then move with a few tweaks to
get
addition subtraction multiplication
essentially arithmetic so
what they but minsky concluded is that
if there's intelligent life somewhere
nature will at least have found the
simplest
possible form of intelligence
namely successor function and in fact
that's
pretty widespread in the uh
organic world so for example ants
can count the number of their steps
if an ant is wandering in the desert and
it wants to know how to get home it
counts up
as a record of the number of steps it's
made and takes them back
so something like successor function is
pretty widespread it's of some interest
that
the successor function the
elements of arithmetic
actually are very closely related to the
core computational properties of human
language
you take the very simplest possible case
of a
possible language a
lexicon with just one word in it
and the most simple computation you get
something like the successor
so it's very likely in many grounds that
if evolution ever reached this point
it would at least have that so the first
point of effort to interact with some
ed and intelligence would be to see if
we can at least
find common ground on arithmetic and
move on from there
uh questions like the ones asked
what they want where are you from why
are you here
that's way off in the distance first you
want to try to see if it's possible
to make some contact at all
you're watching this channel because
you're interested in theoretical physics
consciousness
and the ostensible connection between
the two what's required to follow some
of these arguments is facility with
mathematics as well as discernment of
the underlying physical laws and you may
think that this is beyond you but that's
false
brilliant provides perlucid explanations
of abstruse phenomenon such as
quantum computing general relativity and
even group theory
when you hear that the standard model is
based on u1 cross su-2 cross su-3
that's group theory for example now this
isn't just for neophytes either
for example i have a degree in math and
physics and i still found
some of the intuitions given in these
lessons to vastly aid my penetration
into these subjects for example
electricity and magnetism sign up today
at brilliant.org
toe that is t-o-e for free you'll also
get 20
off the annual premium subscription try
four of the lessons at least don't
stop before four and i think you'll be
greatly surprised at the ease at which
you comprehend subjects you
previously had trouble grocking links
are in the description
okay from the live chat connor mcd
wants to know what's your opinion on the
frankfurt school
it's very hard to answer general
questions like that
um they had some interesting
contributions
uh adorno uh
corkheimer marcuse others
some of it we can learn from my
personally myself i don't get a lot from
it but i think it's worth studying
okay question 30. that's on page three
will wall wants to know do you fear
death why or why not
well when i was about 10 years old
maybe 12 years old i started to think
about
what would happen when i die and what
concerned me was that
when consciousness
ended how could i know whether the world
would even persist
would there be anything else or would
that be the end of the universe
and that was a pretty frightening idea
but it took me about a year or two to
get over it
said yeah i think the world will persist
so
death is part of life enjoy life while
you have it
do what you can with it it'll end the
world will go on
okay the question right before that 29
ivan bilu
why do people have multiple personality
disorders and how do you explain someone
waking up and speaking a foreign
language
well if they're speaking a foreign
language it's a language that they
already knew
they're not going to speak to foreign
language they never
heard before a person who's
lived his whole life in tucson arizona
where i now
am is not going to wake up in the middle
of the night and start speaking swahili
as to why there are personality
disorders
psychology doesn't really understand
this
human mind is a very complex a system
in which you have bare understanding
doesn't reach this form
we know that it happens we know it's a
syndrome
we can try to deal with it but the
sources of it are
well beyond the reach of science at this
point
we don't answer so much simpler
questions about the mind
question 19 similar from brandon from
sacramento
who asks what are professor chomsky's
thoughts
on what are professor chomsky's thoughts
on glossolalia
or speaking in tongues is there an
explanation for why this
is associated with spiritual experience
again it's i've seen it
an evangelical church and
it happens but what's involved in it
again is
far beyond the reach of any scientific
understanding we have to recognize
that science is hard
it's hard to explain even simple things
uh take ants again
just trying to particularly trying to
figure out how the ants in my backyard
can navigate they can navigate way
better than i can
they can you'll deal with properties of
the sun where it is and all sorts of
things that are
way beyond my capacity they do this with
a very
tiny brain minuscule brain
nobody knows how it works um if you
can't answer questions like that
you're not going to answer questions
about psychiatric disorders among humans
you can get some level of understanding
but it's not going to be at any
theoretical depth
i mean questions of
understanding the world are very
difficult
you can't just pose questions saying
let's find an answer too
okay we'll move on to the next one
because your dog seems to not like that
janice via fiamengo asks the innocent
project
is an organization that works toward
exonerating the wrongly convicted
through dna testing and reforms the
criminal justice system to prevent
future injustices at the same time one
of the major planks of modern feminist
movement
is hashtag believe women which has
arrived
which has arised due to the hashtag
metoo movement
which fights for women to stand up
against sexual harassment
and sexual assault do you think there's
a conflict between these two
self-declared libertory projects and
how could that conflict be resolved
always a kind of conflict between
those who make charges against someone
and the person who is the
target of the charges who wants to
exonerate himself
that's what court proceedings are about
it's always a conflict the accused
the accuser has a grievance
the accused may profess innocence
that's what happens in every court of
law every day of the week
this is a particular case of a
far-reaching case
of the innocence project is properly
trying to ask of those who are accused
is there sufficient evidence against
them
the metoo movement is saying
there are plenty of people who are being
abused
not listened to we have to listen to
them
okay so this is a large-scale
highly significant aspect of
any uh legal proceeding
which has an accuser and an acute
how do you deal with it there's no
algorithm
you have to deal with it by thinking
carefully
through the claims
uh the uh
the feelings the attitudes on all sides
and try to adjudicate there is
a presumption of innocence we should
maintain that
we have to assume i think it's correct
to assume
the principle of innocent
until shown to be guilty
proven to be guilty is too strong there
are really no proofs but
ample evidence to demonstrate guilt
short of that we should presume
innocence
that's tough on the abused as they may
not be able to provide the evidence
but i don't think there's a way around
that
we can't even if we
can assume that the abused have a strong
case
unless they can demonstrate it plausibly
it's unfair for the target to be charged
there's no way to defend yourself
number 15 beers attitude from chechnya
asks number 15. realistically what a
human society where the lack of free
will is
the commonly accepted truth be any
different than
than the current human society where
having free will is
sorry let me restate realistically what
a human society where the lack of free
will is the commonly accepted truth be
any different than the current human
society
where having free will is the commonly
accepted truth
there are sub-communities in
our society where
lack of free will is the commonly
accepted truth
a large part of the scientific community
brings believes that
large part of the philosophical world
believes that
i think everything is determined that
freedom of will is just an illusion
actually none of the people who profess
this really believe it
in my opinion they
in fact they're trying to convince you
of it
they're giving reasons uh if we're all
just
thermostats acting
in a totally determined profession
giving reasons is a totally pointless
activity
you don't give reasons to an automaton
it
behaves the way it's going to behave so
my feeling is
intuitively ever all of us
believe that we can make a decision
as to whether say to lift my
little finger or not i can decide do i
want to do that or don't i think
everybody
intuitively believes that there are a
large number of
highly sophisticated brilliant people
who think they can convince themselves
that they can't make that decision
they're among us society functions
exactly
the same for them as it does for us so
the answer to the question
i think is already given to us there are
great many among us some of the most
sophisticated people who think about
these topics
who think there is no free will
everything's determined
do they behave any differently from
anyone else
not detectively they behave like we all
do
question number 18 from ideas
sleep furiously who's the smartest
person chomsky ever met
and does he have any cool anecdotes
about that person
i'm a huge fan of chomsky please don't
let him just say they're all just normal
people i want juicy
gossip this man has met everyone from
rawls to edwitten
nobody's just a normal person
everyone has all kinds of properties
all kind of characteristics abilities
talents i mean i've
there are people i've met in rural
communities
people who can just do anything any
technical problem you present to them
say
my car doesn't work they can look at it
and start to fix it
to me it's impo i'd never have that
talent
some of the smartest people i've ever
met wouldn't just say
throw it out and there's no way to deal
with it
they're just different talents there are
people who are great musicians
can't do many other things i mean
people are what they are i've met lots
of people who are
conventionally very smart uh
you know can you want to ask them a
question about
quantum physics they'll explain it to
you
don't understand the latest ideas and
category theory and mathematics they'll
give you a
lecture about it uh
you want to know about ancient greece
they'll give you
deep commentary on it you want to fix
your motor they'll fix it for you uh
i don't know how to rank people they're
just what they are
with their complex talents abilities
interests and so on there's plenty of
anecdotes about them
is there someone in particular who
impressed you with their intellect
oh plenty of people i could name some
but
we'll exclude others soon just pick one
who's
an old friend from high school was a
friend
until his death a couple years ago
my only high school friend who i stayed
friendly with
hillary putnam brilliant philosopher
mathematician scientist
we were pretty close most of our lives
disagreed on almost everything
but philosophical everything else but
didn't matter
stayed close friends
i mean there are some quite amusing
anecdotes
because i didn't see this myself but a
famous one
has to do with uh her
maybe the greatest mathematician of 20th
century
uh i met him a very strange guy
very brilliant but very strange uh
his two of his close friends
uh albert einstein and
oscar morgenstern decided to try to
convince him
to become an american citizen he was an
immigrant like all of them were so
they have to go to it you go to a place
where you get
tested you know how's the senate elected
that sort of thing
so girdle studied the constitution in
depth
and he came to einstein one day and he
said
there's a problem he found a
contradiction in the constitution
and uh when he goes for his test he's
gonna have to tell the guy that there's
a contradiction in the constitution
so einstein and morgenstern tried to
convince him to
play it down you know not bring it up
and apparently they were able to get him
to do it but that's
that's girdle
you said that kurt girdle was strange
what about him was strange
well i uh i did
was appointed to the institute for
advanced studies back in
1958 where he was a
research senior research
villain and of course i wanted to meet
girdle and so
as soon as i had a chance i made an
appointment with him
went into his office they asked me
politely what kinds of things you're
working on
i said working on language he said
you're wasting your time
it's all been solved by enlightenment
and it turned out he had then i listened
for an hour
to elect her enlivened uh he had about
every book on live nets from the
princeton library in his office and he
was
studying aliveness and death and depth
he was
convinced that leibniz basically had the
answer to everything ronnie had to
detect it by studying carefully what he
had to say
kind of reminded me of a person who
obviously i never met
isaac newton another brilliant figure
who
spent much of his life studying the
church fathers
he was convinced that the church fathers
had
understood things at a level of depth
and insight that
modern humans in his day couldn't attain
but they
put it in a very cryptic fashion so if
you studied the
church fathers in depth you would get
the answers to their questions
well these are maybe the smartest people
you can find anywhere very strange
question 24. this is tobia
davico he or she wants to know
question for professor chomsky has
jacques lacan influenced your thinking
on the nature of language in an in any
way do you recall anything in particular
about your
encounter with them in 1975 thank you
from italy well
jacques lacombe was
i don't remember the year maybe we're 75
was invited to uh
mit by my friend
roman jacobson the very eminent
linguist one of the great humanistic
figures of the 20th century
and um he invited him to give a talk
at mit and uh
nobody was much interested but uh
jakobson convinced
me and close friend morris halley
who was close to jakobson he convinced
us to try to round up an audience for
him
so i managed to convince a lot of
students and others to come
and look on gave a talk
in french which was
so embarrassing that
at the end of roman jakobson was the
moderator
at the end of the talk he people were
kind of
shuffling and looking at each other and
so on
it was embarrassing because it was
boring or because of some other reason
total nonsense
total utter nonsense at the end he
uh asked fortunately it was in french
and plenty of people just didn't
understand it
but those who did understand it were
pretty much uphold at the end jakobson
turned to the audience and said asked
for questions
and nobody had any nobody wanted to say
anything
so he called on me and said would i
like to comment on it
so i had to figure out a way to say
something that was
not embarrassing not stupid and
said something or other and forget what
it was
but the answer to the question is no
there's never been any influence
right so the question you're trying to
not be
embarrassed for yourself or for him when
you were trying to come up with a
question
i had to say something i didn't want to
embarrass
him there was nothing to talk about
about the content of his talk
but somehow say something and that
situation which would
uh be you know
appropriate
not not
harsh of course but not supportive
eithers or just something to
turn the discussion into some possible
direction
i should say that afterwards we all
went out to jakobson took us all out to
dinner at a
fancy restaurant we had fine time with
just
ordinary conversation among people but
in his
professional appearances at least at
that stage of his work
it was in my view pretty embarrassing
now actually he did
earlier work which i've cited sometime
on dream language which i think had some
interest
but that's not the work that he's famous
okay speaking of eating number 28
this is from cuerdo i heard that you are
or were
participating in an anti-aging program
and that a plant-based diet was a part
of it
can you tell us how that's been going
first of all is that even true
oh it's not true i've never heard of any
anti-aging program and if there was one
i wouldn't be participating in it
however it probably is true
that a plant-based diet is
generally good for your health aside
from
many other advantages like
mitigating the torture of animals
uh the very negative effect on
global warming of the
industrial uh
uh production and agriculture and so on
so there may be very good reasons for
moving towards a
more plant-based diet but uh
nothing that i'm involved in my only
anti-aging program is just keep working
okay speaking on that number 22 henry s
is there a practice that you partake in
in particular that keeps your mental
faculties as sharp as they are
as you age do you personally think do
you personally feel as if you've slowed
at all
not particularly slow there are things i
can't do that i used to do
like um i often forget uh
names for example forget phrases
more so than before or you always
that's a normal part of aging
but
the only thing i do is
what's sometimes called the bicycle
theory
long as you keep going fast you don't
fall
so what do you do on a daily basis are
you writing are you reading or
a lot of writing a lot of things like
this
this is had several talks today already
uh some interviews just
tons of mail just constantly working
taking i can't say it or there'll be a
rush to the door
but i will extricate
my animals and the canines well
okay how about 26 noah mueller from
germany asks
is there a connection between language
and movement
does the language i speak actually
change the way
i move does it change the movement
patterns of the speaker
well if you look at anybody speaking
you'll find they're almost always
gesturing
and the gestural aspect is
it does mirror properties of what is
being said
uh emphasis uh focus
the prosody the pitch contours and so on
now this varies from culture to culture
there's some cultures where there's a
very lot of
gestural activity going along with
language there are others in which
people tend to be reserved and
taciturn keep their hands to their sides
and so on
but i think uh these connections exist
i don't know many others
how about question 40 which is laval
2001
he wants to know what does chomsky think
why does chomsky think it's the case
that psychedelics are illegal
and still frowned upon when more
dangerous drugs like
alcohol are legal and even normalized
well remember that that's not always
been the case
there was a time when alcohol was
illegal a whole period of prohibition
and in general when you look at
the whole history of criminalization
of substances it's usually
a kind of class and race war
it's the populations
that are being subdued and controlled
whose drugs are
criminalized so prohibition
was a way to keep the the immigrant
communities who are going to saloons to
keep them
[Music]
under control incidentally through the
whole period of prohibition
if you were a rich new yorker
living in upstate new york nobody was
going to stop you from drinking wine
but if you were an immigrant worker in
downtown new york you couldn't go to
your favorite saloon
now if you look at the
history of not just psychedelics but
even say
marijuana back to the
at the end of prohibition there was a
big federal
apparatus to
to implement the criminalization of
alcohol
and hauser was ahead of it so there was
this huge bureaucracy they had nothing
to do
so they immediately tried to find
something else
to criminalize what they picked was
marijuana
marijuana was commonly used among
mexicans and blacks mexican-americans
and blacks
and therefore that was picked as
the target of criminalization
and there were senate hearings all sorts
of
stories concocted about how marijuana
makes people insane makes them killers
you know
gotta stop it actually that
ended after a while because what
happened was that
criminal lawyers were beginning to
catch on to the fact that you could
mount a criminal
a defense against your client for your
client
by saying he'd been smoking marijuana so
therefore he was not conscious of what
he was doing
well when it got to that point the law
started being changed but
basically it continued to be
criminalization of
the substances being used by parts of
the population who you want to
marginalize and control
psychedelics came later but
the questioner is certainly correct i
mean
drugs like alcohol are
far more dangerous tobacco is more
dangerous than any of them
it's an enormous the number of people
who die from tobacco is
huge but it's never been criminalized
rich powerful people smoke
drug companies the tobacco companies
have of enormous power for decades they
were able to suppress
the uh even the basic information about
uh about the lethal effects of smoking
it's finally been reduced but on a class
basis
so it's now like if you go to a
elite university walk around you won't
see students smoking
but you will see staff smoking
go to a major hospital the doctors won't
be smoking
but the staff may well be
outside because they're not allowed to
smoke into them
so it's turned into a kind of a sort of
a class issue
and it's it's smoking has been
sharply reduced among more educated
sectors of the population
not others but it's never been
criminalized
it was just a drug used by the
wealthy and powerful and there were
major uh
capitalist institutions that just
defended themselves against it
that hasn't been true versus marijuana
of course the use of marijuana is
changing
slowly attitudes are changing walls are
changing it's
different now than it was 20 or 30 years
ago
these are social cultural changes
but it is certainly true that
criminalization had
a very little relation to lethality
to harm was for other other purposes
the last time we spoke you mentioned
that you were uninterested in
mind-altering drugs like psychedelics
and marijuana and so on and i'm curious
is there a reason why is it because of
the stigma or you wanted to keep your
mind sharp
just lack of any interest no particular
reason
i mean you know i was
especially in the 60s when i was very
much involved with
uh youth culture and so on
ever there was marijuana all over the
place but i was never tempted
same with friends just not interested
okay number four joshua bronco wants to
know
if you have any thoughts on frederick
nietzsche
number four do you have any thoughts on
the work of frederick nietzsche
oh my main thought is i wish i had time
to read his work more carefully
did you find it provocative interesting
false
the little i've read which is not much
is
highly highly intriguing and interesting
but among the myriad things that i
haven't had time to study that's one
okay the question right before this
three
ravi ray want from hong kong wants to
know do you think that we can
objectively determine that some works of
art
are better than others
well i think we can determine it
actually i have a criterion i use
to decide whether something's a work of
art
uh if i could do it it's not a work of
yeah art uh one objective criterion
but uh we know somehow it's not easy
changes over time um attitudes as
to what understanding is to what the
great works of art are
do change over time but they do
kind of coalesce you can you somehow
know
how do you know it's a matter of what's
the nature of our
aesthetic capacities i
a serious art critic can be very helpful
in explaining
what it is that it is about
say a great work of art that's not true
of
something i would draw but uh
and is that objective it's
it's not just i mean there are objective
criteria
but understanding of how this works is
another one of those problems that's
pretty well beyond their
comprehension that we can gain very
very intriguing understanding of it when
you read a
serious art critic like
say myers shapiro or the h gombridge you
learn a lot
at least i do and it changes your
appreciation
and understanding okay
number eight beers attitude wants to
know what are chomsky's views on
anti-natalism
don't really see any point to it if you
don't want to have children
fine but if uh
why we should decide that uh
other lives should not exist
i don't see any that i have any right to
say that
what if they say what if they want to
know do you view having children as
unethical because it contributes to
environmental problems or overpopulation
forget about mandating it or legalizing
or not legalizing it contributes to
problems it also contributes to progress
we want to have works of art for example
or scientific understanding or technical
solutions to the problems around us
they're going to come from people you
don't have people
you don't have the contributions
okay someone from the chat drory wants
to know
this is just from the chat if a complex
language is unique
but other species collaborate on group
projects
is it possible it was a devolution
was the innovation around lying
i don't understand the question do you
no i don't
i'm sorry i don't see it on the chat
either
is it on the chat yeah it's on the chat
i don't know why i'm not seeing him okay
we're going to move on drury if you can
you can rewrite that
how number 10 hamad from iran asks what
do you think of it
from bit from john wheeler
he said great physicist
met him impressive person
[Music]
competent physicist taken quite
seriously
i'm not competent to judge actually i
am competent to judge that i'll have to
leave i'm afraid
oh okay that's fine that's fine before
you go the last question then the one
right before this about stephen pinker
that one you should be competent enough
to judge
jens from belgium asks what do you think
of stephen pinker's words
and rules theory of language where
regular verbs rely on rules and
irregular verbs rely on
lexical memory thanks well when
pinker produced that book it was a
contribution
but it's now been superseded by uh
much more far-reaching work especially
work by
charles yang a computation
computer scientist linguist and now at
the university of pennsylvania
did very exciting work on
[Music]
a lot of it's in a book called the price
of productivity
where he developed a general method
a sophisticated method to determine the
conditions
under which someone acquiring a language
would pick rules rather than lists
and it gives very precise answers
to the course of development of
children in the
well-documented process of when they use
regular verbs irregular verbs and so on
but now it's based on after his work on
really serious understanding
of the fundamental mechanisms and what's
involved
so that supersedes all previous work on
this topic
it's very sophisticated chomsky
thank you so much i'm humbled every time
we speak i'm a huge admirer of you
thank you so much nice to be with you
thank you all i'm looking through the
chat i hadn't
i didn't have a chance to ask all of
your questions or almost any of your
questions on the chat
it's extremely difficult for me to pay
attention to chomsky which i want to do
i don't want to
keep looking down it's rude and it takes
me out of the moment
but at the same time i do want to answer
your questions you're kind enough to
watch live and
interested enough to type it's a
delicate balance
and i tend to choose the guest over the
chat
okay well everyone thanks so much for
watching
have a great one
you